let me bring in mark Stein he's a busy
man covering the NBA New York Times
senior NBA writer I likened it to
Christmas we talked about it all year
long and then it took about seven
minutes to open up the gifts yesterday
was yesterday a good day great day bad
day for the NBA it's hard to see it as
anything other than a great day I mean
look by the letter of the law I think we
can hope that some stuff is happening
here it should not be happening because
it would be this is you know I've
covered a few of these while this day
one by far there's not even a second
place I mean we've never seen day one
action like that but it also helps when
you have a weak lead-up I mean it's been
from where I'm sitting in my dungeon
where I track all this stuff we've been
at Full Tilt than a week ago so a lot of
conversations have been happening and
teams are ready to go you know we got we
it was it was a very good day you have a
lot of these teams that are making moves
and it feels like the Clippers and the
Lakers and the Raptors are not there it
feels like there are three teams waiting
for one player it's that a fair
assessment of what you know the scenario
yesterday and today there's a lot
there's a lot three teams that they're
really the only three teams at this
point that that have any hope of getting
Kawhi and when it's a player of that
level you have to wait so you know both
the Lakers and the Clippers look Toronto
has been living under this risk from the
minute they got Kawhi Leonard the minute
they got it on July 18 2018 they've been
hearing how the Clippers were going to
steal him or the Lakers an LA team was
gonna steal him so the Raptors know this
feeling but for the Clippers and the
Lakers it's an uneasy feeling because
you know there's a chance neither gets
them and Kauai decides to say and then
then where are you when basically
everyone you wanted is gone well what's
the Lakers plan B what's Clippers Plan B
and what's Toronto's plan B well the
Clippers Plan B is much more appealing
they can just continue to do
what they've been doing and you know
they they will be in the mix for you
know future moves you know their
timetables not as pressing LeBron James
turns 35 in December the Lakers need
they obviously getting Davis was huge
for them but besides Cal Kuzma there's
nothing else they're really they just
don't have much of a team so I mean
their whole plan was to either convince
Kauai to come or maybe a fallback like a
DeAngelo Russell or a Malcolm Brogdon
well DeAngelo Russell and Malcolm
Brogdon are aren't available anymore so
the Lakers it's a Matt the Lakers really
need to convince collided to do this
Toronto
if Kauai decides to leave Toronto is is
on a different track and again that's
that's the risk that they accepted when
they made the deal I mean they made the
deal knowing that this might only be a
one-year marriage and you know they won
the ultimate prize so I think they'll
have to accept it there's been a report
of numerous reports that the Knicks
didn't offer Kevin Durant the max deal
but this is what hasn't been reported
yet mark even if you did offer him the
max wasn't he going to Brooklyn anyway
that that's where Kyrie was going they
were trying to get DeAndre Jordan there
it's easy to criticize the Knicks but in
this situation I'm just looking at this
logically you know maybe the Knicks
didn't feel like they wanted to give him
that extra year all right fine but that
does if they give him that gave him that
extra year then Kevin Durant is now
gonna go there instead of the Nets
I don't see that it's terrible for the
Knicks that this is coming out okay the
reality is that James Dolan has had this
position about being hesitant to give
him the max for days and days before
this got to the finish line but your
larger point stance the Knicks the
Knicks in the end weren't even in the
room when Kevin Durant was deciding and
he you know the initial indications were
that we might see Durant take the bulk
of this week to make the decision he
ended up making it on day one and
announcing it in minute one the
hood that's how that's how locked he was
on the nets at the end so look at
terrible optics for the Knicks but the
Knicks lost this because of of what
they've become I mean and so there is
some some culpability for dole in there
I mean he has to own this for lack of a
better word I mean he's the one in March
publicly out and touted that creates
he's gonna good to us and God people
hopes up so the max no max thing people
are going to fixate on that today but
but but there are bigger problems and I
you know I said it immediately after we
got the Durant was becoming a Knick if
this doesn't make Dolan take a step back
but the Knicks brand has become under
his watch and that the net it could get
two of the most coveted names in the
game and the Knicks get nothing I mean
he who has to look at himself will he I
don't know but that that's the issue
more than the the max are no mask he's
mark Stein covers the NBA for the New
York Times joining a Stan Patrick's show
best move or moves made yesterday were
by who well nothing good a Trump what
the Nets did because isn't a great deal
the dream scenario but you know the
under-the-radar team is New Orleans what
the pelicans are doing the the number of
moves and quality players on some good
deals that David Griffin is brought in
what happened with David Griffin and the
pelicans in what is it six weeks since
he's been in sgt he's completely changed
the perception of that franchise it's
it's amazing obviously there's a huge
slice of luck in it you can't you get
you know the spurs will tell you hey we
were lucky we were in the lottery twice
and we got Duncan and Robinson you do
need luck
so Diane Williamson they can't claim any
any mastery there but everything else
they've done around that has been an a
maybe a plus
first move were smooth I mean look I I'm
everybody wants to do winners and losers
and it's too hard to do that at this
point but I mean obviously there are
teams out there that are coming away
with nothing and look the Knicks have
certainly raised eyebrows with the money
they've spent on you know I thought that
yields would be shorter and smaller in
the wake of not getting Durant and
Irving
you know they've decided to to spend
more I think and on a lot of front core
players the people were anticipating but
I think also we need to we need to see
we need to see where the Lakers and
Clippers shake out here too soon for me
to call that one you is your sense that
Kauai is going to the Lakers I gotta be
honest it's I'm hesitant to say what my
sense is cuz it's so fluid and then
everybody wants to say hey you said this
I mean that's that's the thing it's
remarkably fluid you know I think the
last time we visited I would have said
the Lakers weren't even in it and they
they've you know now they're right at
the forefront of it you know the
prevailing reaction I think you get when
you talk to people around the league is
why would Kauai want to go there the guy
just led a team to a title why does he
want to join with LeBron and with a B
you know it doesn't make any sense but
it again speaks to how we don't really
know what he wants and and what
motivates him he's won two titles he's
won two Finals MVPs frankly from a
legacy standpoint Kawhi Leonard can do
whatever he wants so if he wants to be a
Laker if that's what he decides is the
most appealing thing if he wants to go
somewhere where he can share the burden
and that can be left taxing on him
physically you know maybe he's gonna
maybe he's gonna choose the Lakers my
you know my personal view has always
been stay in Toronto for one more year
do the one in one run it back with the
team that just won the championship
you're the Eastern Conference favorites
if you stay stay one more
year then do what you want but this
won't surprise you Kauai has not called
to seek my counsel on this I have a
friend who's affiliated with the Golden
State Warriors and he gave me a heads up
a while ago he said you know even if we
lose KD the Golden State will do
something that will surprise you and so
when I solve D'Angelo Russell going
there and he goes are you surprised I go
yeah I am how does this work for Golden
State with D'Angelo Russell if you're
friend with calling the D'Angelo Russell
SOT I would like his number well no no
he wasn't he just said that that they
were going to do something because I you
know I said look there's sneaky great
that they'll they'll do something you're
not gonna lose Katie and go though Oh
what was me we're moving into a new
building you want to keep momentum going
and I assume they were gonna do
something I did not think and he did not
say D'Angelo Russell yeah surprise
doesn't even begin to I mean that is but
you know what it next year their season
is gonna be so fascinating because basic
this is all about the future
D'Angelo Russell doesn't fit there what
so ever this was exactly how you
described it they just wanted to make
sure that they did not see Kevin Durant
arguably the best player in the league
when healthy walk out the door for
nothing they got a 23 year old all-star
and they will trade him it's just a
matter of when do they keep him for a
whole season hmm do they do they trade
him do they even trade him at midseason
but you know Stefan curry and klay
Thompson you might have heard of them
they're pretty pretty renowned backcourt
those guys aren't going anywhere so
there really isn't move there isn't room
for ferjeen's low obviously clay is
going to miss the bulk of next season so
in the short term yes but this was
really about the Warriors protecting
themselves for the future and next
season this first season in this new
palace there they've built in San
Francisco it's really all about setting
them up for the future they've got it
they want to be able in year two to move
forward at the level that we've been
accustomed to watching them for the last
five years
great stuff marked throughout this
since we appreciate your time as always
all right guys thank you Mark Steyn New
York Times senior NBA writer for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]